[Music]
hey guys it's justine and today we have
the brand new m2 macbook air in the
studio let's open it up and we'll chat
about what's new
the box has been opened i didn't even
need a knife
here it is
wow so this is the midnight color it
definitely looks a lot darker i feel
like when i first saw this because of
the lighting but now that we're here in
the studio with some controlled lighting
you can definitely see the hint of blue
on it and it's really really beautiful
it's such a nice look let's open it up
you're just there to
to greet us it's wild because it just
looks like a very squished down version
of the macbook pro oh my goodness they
already want me to get started hold on a
second i need to see what else is in the
box so we've got the magsafe braided
cable and i love that this is the same
color as the macbooks each color will
coordinate with whichever color macbook
you get see they really should have went
all out though and made the usbc
attachment the same color next time they
did do that for the magsafe attachment
let's see if we've got any stickers in
here like you know there's stickers in
here it's like it goes without even
saying unless there's not and then i'll
be very sad don't worry justine is not
sad here they are and they match the
macbook
same color
how pretty and we've got our charging
brick here
this is the dual charging power adapter
this is the 35 watt and this is pretty
cool because you'll be able to
charge two things at the same time and
what this does is it'll allocate
depending upon how much power each item
needs that's plugged in to use english
as the main language press the return
key
uh okay
i guess we're setting this up now i
wasn't ready mac os contains a built-in
screen reader called voiceover hi i'm
siri hi i'm siri hi i'm siri hi hi hi hi
hi hi okay what do we want do we want
light mode dark mode or do we want
automatic i think i'm gonna go with
light mode there it is it's all set up
oh my god i'm so excited to start
testing this out so this is the m2 chip
and this currently has 16 gigs of ram
and we have the one terabyte storage
these can be configured up to 24 gigs of
ram which is pretty impressive there's
four color options this is the new
midnight and it's joined by silver space
gray and starlight it has an all
aluminum unibody with 20 reduction in
volume compared to the previous macbook
air model the display is a 12.6 inch
liquid retina with 500 nits of
brightness which is 25 brighter the
facetime camera is now 1080p with
improved low light performance and the
speakers are right between the keyboard
and display giving a four speaker sound
system for separation and spatial audio
now the battery on this is also very
impressive with up to 18 hours of video
playback it has two usbc ports magsafe
high impedance headphone jack 8 core gpu
10 core cpu and in an all fanless super
quiet design there's also some new
charging options this is the new compact
35 watt power adapter with two usb c
ports that can allocate power based on
which devices are plugged into it if you
do want fast charging though you're
going to want to use the 67 watt usbc
power adapter for it this will allow you
to get up to 50 charge in just 30
minutes so now this is all set up i'm
gonna install some of my favorite apps
of course the first thing that i always
do install is final cuts and i always
install photoshop those are pretty much
my two go-to's and it's also very
exciting because i did a really fun
partnership with motion vfx and this is
the company that i use for all of my
plugins and all of my youtube videos we
came out with a really fun pack called m
keynote it has a ton of effects
transitions animations text titles
overlays all kinds of really cool stuff
so if you guys want to get that i'll put
a link in the description and you may
notice that i've been using them
throughout this video so the overall
design of this it is the new unibody
aluminum and before the previous macbook
model it had like a slanted design
whereas this is kind of taking more of
the form factor of the macbook pros i
mean it really does look like a squish
down version so let me just show you
kind of where macbook air started from
and some other kind of comparisons brand
new m2 here we are started from the top
and we're gonna go to the bottom which
is the original macbook air which is
right here i mean look at this thing
this
is so wild to see
the differences especially when we flip
this around when you guys see the
screens when this macbook air was first
announced it was revolutionary the fact
that it was hidden inside of a manila
envelope steve pulled the laptop out and
the crowd
did in fact
[Applause]
this is the new macbook air and to kind
of see it transition into a little bit
larger of a version but with this all
new form factor it's pretty exciting
because since the beginning it has
always had kind of this wedge shape
design um i i dropped it so we can just
disregard that next up this is kind of
an interesting comparison this is the
macbook this is not a macbook air but
it's kind of cool to see how tiny
tiny tiny this little guy is and this is
when they still had the butterfly
keyboard which i was a fan hater's gonna
hate
but i actually really liked it the new
air does have the all-new magic keyboard
which i think a lot of people really do
like but hey butterfly keyboard haters i
was a supporter so this is the macbook
air of one of the previous models and
this has that wedge-shaped design so
when we put that up next to the new one
you can really see the difference the
one thing that it did not have though
was magsafe and why this is really key
for the new macbook air is this will
give you those two ports free so you
don't have to worry about losing a port
to charge you can have access to both of
those ports and one of the things to
note too is the speaker placement so the
speakers on the previous models were on
the side here so now the new speakers
are integrated into the actual device
itself so they are not visible which
gives it kind of a more seamless look
and less places to spill drinks into and
snacks
so we like that so this is the 14 inch
macbook pro and i want to show you guys
the comparison so you can see the
differences between the size
of the 14 inch
and
the new air
because they do have a very similar body
but this one is just squished down and a
little bit slimmer and as for top down
you'll see there is a little bit of
extra space there as far as the weight
goes
oh yeah the air is way lighter so the
pro does have three usbc it does have
hdmi and an sd card slot and this does
not have an sd card slot or hdmi and you
are losing one usb c port so it does
really depend on what you're going to be
doing with your laptop do you need a pro
version can you get away with using the
air for pretty much anything that you're
going to need day to day this air is
going to be more than powerful for you
and the last comparison that i want to
do is to the 13 inch
macbook
pro it's pro this does have a sticker on
it that's our same brain logo for my
podcast this was the first m1 macbo pro
to come out this was honestly such a
game changer because this is really what
showed us the power of the m1 chip so
kind of seeing these two next to each
other is a pretty beautiful experience
because now that we're at m2 this
macbook air is one of the first ones to
get the m2 chip so we started here now
we're here and that means my friends
it's time to finally test this out
okay we just finished filming the
unboxing and now we're gonna transfer
some footage and there's something that
i noticed is i almost have always been
using dark mode on my macbooks that have
the notch so i never noticed the notch
and it is definitely noticeable
in light mode which is why i never
really it doesn't even bother me because
i never really saw it before so we're
gonna
we're gonna go back to dark mode because
this is a crime
look at that way
way better oh the typing feels nice
first usbc
and that's
how we do it
oh my god my stomach's growling i'm
hungry we need a thumbnail you're dusty
is you all clean you look good
you did
you oh oh
oh my god
well you know what
i'm gonna have a thumbnail for you i
gotta find it
a cam into there
transferring two cards at once love that
yeah we should definitely take a
thumbnail before we leave can you see
these
yes
do we want this here or do we like just
this
okay
uh
how's that yeah okay
how's the reflection
uh i like the onions okay yeah perfect
okay cool i think it's good
all right let's go get food
so we're taking a little lunch break and
i'm going to set up my final cut project
where's the computer just seen oh it's
in here look at this i fit the entire
laptop in here i have my charging cable
everything is so
tiny and it's perfect i love it look at
this
it's a piece of my hair it's cool
you saw nothing let's get this project
started
so it does get a little smudgy but the
good news is it wiped off quite nice so
that is definitely something to think
about when you are getting the darker
macbook the color looks so beautiful
especially out here in the sunlight
love it love to see it
[Music]
oh that was fast so i got my project
started and i just made a three camera
multi-cam clip pretty much instantly
like it was super fast and all of this
footage is directly out of the sony i
didn't make any proxy footage nothing i
just brought it right in
[Music]
so we got three angles here i always
like to make sure that this
table is lined up so i got to do a
little
slight adjustment and here we go we've
got
all three of our camera angles right
there if i want to switch angles i just
can hit one
two
three
so i had lunch off camera i got my edit
started and i kinda want some ice cream
so i'm gonna go get some ice cream and
continue my edit there i love this thing
so much so far
oh no they're closed 3 p.m
i'll just work on my computer and
i'll wait
i have no problem waiting for ice
[Music]
cream so we're five minutes away from
ice cream could not be more excited it's
also really great because i've already
started this edit so as you guys are
watching this this video is done just
know this was edited while i'm sitting
here waiting for ice cream i pretty much
have most of the unboxing done so far
editing has been going pretty great and
the one thing about this macbook air is
it doesn't have a fan in it so when it
does start getting warm that's sometimes
where you'll see some of the processor
lag a little bit and
i'm not plugged in i'm editing a three
camera multi-cam clip in this final cut
timeline right now and i do feel
the macbook air getting a little warm
like it's nothing
at all to compare like it used to be
with like the intel max but i just want
to say that i've noticed that it is
getting warm so that's where the pro
kind of comes into play because
obviously that does have bands so you
can push that a little bit harder
whereas this one you are kind of limited
to the temperature constraints that this
has but so far i am editing like a champ
and i haven't had any sort of setbacks
i just can't even decide like what i
want because i want all of it
[Music]
okay let's go outside and enjoy this
delicious treat wow we keep editing
[Music]
the life of an editor
it's not always this easy this could not
be any more unrealistic of the life of
an editor but hey maybe we start a trend
this macbook starts getting hot full of
ice cream under there cool you down this
is freaking delicious
i did not need two scoops
so we're back after the ice cream and
lunch break and i want to show you guys
the plug-in pack that i made with motion
vfx called m keynote but first
i need to light a candle
the new mac smell
to set the mood
smells just like a new mac to me so
here's the plug-in pack and you're gonna
download m installer this also works for
not only final cut but also for premiere
and davinci resolve and here it is i'm
gonna click install i already have it
purchased on my computer also i'm gonna
install mkbhds both of those look like
they're installed i'm going to open up
final cut pro and these are all right
here in the titles
so we've got mkbhds and my m keynote
we've got all kinds of backgrounds we
have boards and our little call to
actions here which i'm going to use one
of these as my title
and it's great because these are all
customizable so i can change the colors
and i can make them look however i want
and since this is the midnight macbook
i'm going to change the color to like a
dark blue
so you guys want to check that out or
any of the other plugins from motion vfx
i'll put a link in the description one
of the things that i like to do when i'm
doing comparisons or even just review
videos like this is go to apple's
website they have the option to pick
which products you want and can compare
them to each other now as with all of
these things there obviously is price
differences but i feel like if you are
someone who is going to be keeping this
computer for a really long time you are
going to want to upgrade the ram and the
storage as much as possible the great
news is what i usually say about storage
is you can always use external drives
but as great as it is to be able to use
external drives there are some times
where i just want to have my laptop and
i don't want to have anything attached
to it and you will be surprised how
quickly things do add up on your
computer hey justine here from the
future
ironically i got to the part where i was
talking about storage and i got a
notification in final cut that says i
have run out of storage this is only a
one terabyte drive so basically that
means this entire video i haven't
completely shot and i'm editing
everything directly off of the drive and
i have officially filled it up for me i
would not be able to just get by on a
one terabyte drive storage space aside i
have been incredibly impressed with this
performance so far like i actually
haven't really felt like i'm editing on
a macbook air at all normally i would do
these types of edits on my macbook pro
and it almost feels
very similar to editing on my macbook
pro as far as how seamless it's going so
i am more than impressed with how final
cut has been handling this so far so
i've been editing all day and now i'm
back and my battery is getting a little
bit low i haven't charged this at all
since i took it out of the box so this
is gonna be the first time that i'm
charging it so let's plug in our mag
safe right here
hey jack chamber boom we were talking
about
thumbnails yeah
what about
thumb drives
that's terrible
i know it's not
he's gone bye
i deserve that but come on this is
really cool like thumb drive i'm gonna
paint the nail
anyway where was i so i'm gonna continue
editing the video that you just watched
but this is kind of a first look at my
first impressions of the m2 macbook air
i'm really excited and when the first m1
came out with that 13-inch macbook pro i
knew
that the future of the apple silicon
chips was going to be game changer and i
could not be more correct in that
thinking the fact that you are able to
run up to 11 streams of prores 4k on a
macbook air is incredibly impressive i
was editing this 3-cam multi-cam clip
without it even being converted to
prores it was just straight off my sony
camera did nothing just brought it in
and i was already able to edit in
addition to that you can also edit two
streams of 8k which is also pretty
impressive i do want to run some further
tests and we will be doing a follow-up
video so i would love to hear from you
guys what would you like to see me test
out on this leave those in the comments
below and i will see you guys in my next
video make sure you subscribe hit the
bell to be notified when i post new
videos and i'll see you in the next one
we got a two terabyte storage but what i
love so much about the macbook air is it
is so small portable and compact